chers amis chers concitoyens citoyens de
russie
la première semaine qui avait été
déclarée comme semaines de congés
s'achève dans un régime soutenu les
médecins les infirmières et tout le
personnel soignant continue à travailler
et leur situation est aujourd'hui
difficile ce sont eux qui dans les
hôpitaux dans les centres de lutte
contre les infections dans tous les
établissements hospitaliers men
l'essentiel de la lutte en soignant en
souvent les gens et en mettant un frein
à la progression de la maladie et je
suis convaincu que tous les citoyens de
notre pays
s'associeront à ses paroles de
reconnaissance envers le personnel
soignant d'autres personnels dans
d'autres domaines de la vie travaille
aussi activement et je tiens à les
remercier à vous remercier tous sans
exception et notamment les volontaires
les bénévoles qui s'investissent dans ce
travail et à tous les citoyens qui ont
bien compris leur responsabilité
personnelle dans la situation les
médecins spécialistes remplissent les
instructions données par le gouvernement
les proches s'occupe des personnes qui
sont malades chez eux et donc cette
semaine de congé a été proclamée pour
l'ensemble du pays et les mesures de
restriction ont été étendues à
l'ensemble du pays à d'autres régions
et aujourd'hui tous les organes de
pouvoir toutes les structures toutes les
ressources de santé sont investis
aujourd'hui pour résister autant que
possible à cette infection à cette
épidémie
et nous nous appuyons aussi sur la
pratique dans d'autres pays ce qui me
paraît essentiel c'est que pour
l'instant nous avons réussi à protéger
en général la génération âgée le
troisième âge
nous avons évité une propagation dans
les institutions et les établissements
d'enseignement et que faut-il faire
ensuite quelles seront nos décisions je
le sous type je le souligne pour prendre
ses décisions il faut bien comprendre
que ce risque se maintient et comme le
disent les spécialistes en virologie le
pic de l'épidémie n'est pas encore passé
notamment dans notre pays
pour cette raison j'ai pris la décision
de poursuivre cette semaine de congé
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril c'est à
dire jusqu'au 30 avril
avec le maintien des salaires
je vous explique la situation évolue et
dans les régions selon les régions selon
les mêmes les municipalités nous avons
vous le savez un pays qui est très grand
ou nous avons différentes densités de
population il y à des entités de la
fédération de russie où le corps navires
us a provoqué des situations assez
difficile notamment par exemple à moscou
malgré toutes les mesures qui ont été
prises et il ya des régions où
malheureusement elles sont de moins en
moins nombreuse où il n'y a encore aucun
cas de l'infection
donc les restrictions doivent être
renforcés d'une manière générale à
d'autres endroits elles doivent être au
contraire adapté mais aujourd'hui nous
avons des décisions qui sont ponctuels
et locales donc il faut prendre en
compte ce qui se produit
et par conséquent sur mon ordre les
responsables régionaux vous recevoir des
compétences supplémentaires et ils
devront très prochainement prendre des
mesures complètement con complémentaire
de confinement pour préserver la santé
des citoyens mais aussi préserver
l'essentiel du fonctionnement des
structures économiques jeu elle le
répète les régions sont objectivement
dans des situations variées mais elles
doivent concrètement en fonction de leur
situation locale prendre des décisions
des décisions en application de mes
instructions
donc je vais indiquer quels sont les
secteurs économiques qui doivent arrêter
leur activité et quels sont les secteurs
qui doivent au contraire poursuivre par
ailleurs comme part comme par le passé
les établissements médicaux les organes
de pouvoir les magasins de produits de
première nécessité et tous les services
sociaux maintiennent leurs activités si
des restrictions doivent s'imposer par
la suite dont notamment dans situe dans
le domaine de l'enseignement dans le
domaine de la formation
les régions devront valider ses
décisions avec les organes de pouvoir
fédéral aujourd'hui il est très
important de bien coordonner le et en
même temps de bien distinguer les
domaines de responsabilité différents
niveaux de pouvoir et donc il faut
procéder à une juste coordination et
toutes les informations doivent être
recentré au niveau du centre
d'information près le
gouvernement et toutes les décisions
doivent être prises en fonction des
informations qui seront regroupés et les
organes régionaux doivent être validés
bien évidemment toutes leurs décisions
avec les services sanitaires et entier
épidémique là l'objectif maximal est de
préserver la sécurité et la santé des
citoyens
compte tenu de la situation nous allons
donc prendre b6 des décisions
complémentaires et si nécessaire nous
maudire modifierons la période de congés
indiqué peut-être même pour la réduire
mais je veux être bien clair et je tiens
à le souligner les mesures de lutte
contre l'épidémie ne doivent pas nous
faire oublier que il est important de
préserver l'emploi de la population et
les salaires c'est une priorité absolue
pour le gouvernement pour les
entreprises pour les régions c'est à
dire assurer la stabilité de l'économie
et cela entre en compte dans toutes les
décisions que nous prenons aujourd'hui à
tous les niveaux chers citoyens de
russie
je vous demande de continuer à faire
preuve de respect et d'attention aux
décisions qui sont prises par les
organes de pouvoir et par les médecins
prenez soin de vos proches
ce qui sera très important c'est notre
responsabilité commune et notre entraide
entre tous même cette brève semaines de
congés nous a permis de réduire les
risques mais nous voyons que nous allons
devoir continuer à travailler ensemble
et de façon fiable et en devançant les
obstacles
je vous remercie pour votre attention
soyez en bonne santé portez vous bien